solaria leave me victory here means
death I once thought the save my whole
world before you arrived fire to the
west is a colossus web Waygate deploying
eldar in great numbers Eastwood fair
also working to activate another
Colossus gate together we can conquer
these perils and the others that await
us
you are all certain first we must put
these elder to the sword
tactical marines ready
just the roar of a salvos or cualquier
me
we are ready
existence of cruel really
I am this one is your lowly servant
preparing cycles for deployment the
Dauntless is feeding signals from
bloodraven transponders it should
investigate I believe it's for our
fathers have joined you on the cage
enemies awaits Daniel man come on dr.
gone
this day holds glory doing it now
funny
rincon de Lorean fray
annihilator is in drop position promise
listen close show us at we are ready for
war we shall remove which is a plasma
tactical squad
Loria here SIA they are marching towards
our stronghold from the east gate
servitor Eastwood
tactical marines rise shine
Donald indoors and attack elder warriors
are seating a song called the of engage
the week and a listening post is active
go ahead come on Space Marines ready
my pleasure
our stronghold is taking elder fire my
brothers are met by a strong enemy force
west
you come on us
they're warriors are attacking our main
stronghold of Marines report ready to
drop
belay that calling off reinforcements
preparing las calles devastators for
deployment
tactical squad our voices our thunder
as canon devastators are ready upon the
field you have need of miles de la
famille pleasure that's kind of charged
everything
bass cannon devastators already upon the
field
targan cleared
towards our base
Raven you
five
readying for trot we have legal oh look
to our vulnerable listening post destroy
the tree attacking
this week
photography by our folks
you